hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys have been requesting as
soon as it finished uh it is team
uzbekistan versus team india one now and
on board one we have not rebecca sutra
versus pentala hari krishna another beck
still on a perfect score with five wins
zero losses zero draws and hare krishna
uh doing great not losing a single game
so far but he does have two wins and two
draws and this game it really shows how
uh even in today you know in 2022 uh the
the joko piano or the italian game can
still be as
bloody as it was uh in like in the days
maybe when joaquin or greco played it so
let's uh dive straight into it
abdusatrov has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 with e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c for going
for the italian game bishop to c5 going
for the joko piano and now pawn to d3 i
thought that there was
maybe a slight chance that we might see
an evans gambit here as uzbekistan
players have been the one to play it for
from time to time but uh you know in in
faster events uh but this is olympia
this classical so now we stick with what
is best the joko pianissimo we have pawn
to d3 knight to f6 and here comes uh the
the move that i believe made the game as
interesting as it was
and that is bishop to g5 here there are
a lot of other moves that are much more
popular like castle c3 knight b to d2
but bishop to g5 uh it allows black um a
very very unique set of moves that uh
well yeah
you'll see what i mean by this but it's
just very hard for white to uh prove any
any sort of advantage here so i think
it's very interesting that abdusatrov
chooses this
uh we have h6 by hari krishna of course
this is what you have to play bishop to
h4 now pawn to d6 we have castles and
now
usually everyone just goes g5 here you
kick away the bishop then you
shift this knight over to g6 you start a
kingside attack and you know everyone
knows this however here uh instead of
this we have the immediate pawn to a5
krishna knows that in order to play well
against white you have to prevent white
from playing b4 at all cost so there
will be time to play on the king side
but it's essential to play a5
so it is now as of move 7 that we have a
completely new game and okay pawn to c3
now preparing to play a3b for d4 and so
on uh bishop back to a7 the bishop will
be much safer here also you don't have
to worry about any pawns uh gaining
tempe on it we have ponte a4 and now a
ponte g5 attacking the bishop bishop g3
and 97 the knight is now coming to
the g6 and then this net might come to
h5 to harass the bishop and so on the
bishop here is a monster just
controlling this entire diagonal and you
you will
well you're basically going to have to
worry about it for the rest of the game
so here queen to b3 now this is again a
moment where things get very very
interesting there are many other moves
that you can you know choose to play
like knight a3 bringing the knight over
to b5 try and harass that bishop brook
to e1
but queen to b3 is very very aggressive
goes after the f7 pawn and he's
basically asking hare krishna are you
going to castle uh and hari krishna does
we have castles knight beat d2 and now
knight to g6 so the setup is you know
same as always
and here we have pawn to d4 uh so also
white has a lot of pressure on black's
king side but uh it seems that it's just
easier for black to put pressure on the
white knight to h5 now going after the
bishop on g3 and here as the title
suggests uh you should never you know
underestimate the power of moving your
king if you castle queenside you know
just move the king the further left and
if you've castle kingside move the king
all the way to the right you you do not
want your king here ever
and king to h1 is is the way to continue
playing this uh however here after d
captures on e5 uh abdusathrov's position
is dead lost uh but only if uh
pentala finds a move and he does he
plays knight captures and g3 we have h
capture sun g3 and now he plays d
captures on e5 which uh uh you know uh
gives back the advantage a little bit
here the uh uh you know just uh the
immediate way to win is pawn to g4 and
now how are you playing this uh the
problem is this knight is guarding this
knight once you move this knight and
this opens up this is a problem and also
this is a problem uh the bishop still
just you know a complete monster and
also once you play h5h4 this is a
problem so although this seems like many
moves uh problem is after knight to h2
we just play one to h5 and now uh what
do you play if he captures and e6 just
queen captures on d6 and you resign here
there's no
there's no defense this is hanging queen
captures and g3 is a threat um as as the
df pawn is pinned you're still just
going to play h4 capture i mean
there's no defending this so one reason
why i believe hari krishna did not go
for this uh is that
after g4 maybe you don't have to move
the knight maybe you can play rook eight
to d1 and it's an incredibly complicated
continuation but one that you would
definitely expect from nodribeck dame
so if g captures an f3 knight captures
now the white rook controls the d-file
and after let's say queen e7 e captures
on these six pawn captures now knight to
d4 blocking the bishop also may be
coming to f5 with all of this pressure
uh could be very dangerous but still
black should black should be perfectly
fine here if black does not blunder all
that much so here after a capture sun g3
this is best
hari krishna first goes for d characters
on e5 and now we have rook 8 to d1
aligning the the rook with the queen but
hari krishna just goes g for right away
he attacks the knight knight to h2 and
now queen to g5
so how do you how do you defend here we
have rook f to e1 and now king to g7 uh
unpinning from this uh diagonal we have
rook to e2 adding a defender here and
now pawn to h5 preparing h4 and of
course h captures and g3 we have knight
to d to f1 adding another defender here
but just ponte h4 and now uh the way to
defend this is to actually capture uh
this is the the way to do it if queen
captures we just kick away the queen
with the g3 and if knight captures then
we play rook to d3 and this should hold
you know uh with with perfect play of
course however after h4 rook the d3
right away was played and now hari
krishna is allowed to capture on g3
himself so h characters and g3 rook
captures on g3 and now knight to f4
going after the rook here and now there
is no good way to save the rook uh
problem is if you move the rook just
knight h5 goes after this rook and now
if you want to save this rook you have
to play rook to d3 and then just g3 and
white resigns there is no defense here
of course
this is impossible so any trades here on
the g3 square are favorable for black
captures captures of course the f1 is
pinned and if you can't capture and you
just have to wait for
black to capture then that's game over
so here instead of moving the rook he
tries knight captures on g4 which looks
plausible as the queen and king are on
the g file uh but
uh well hari krishna is here to prove
otherwise bishop captures on g4 and not
knight the e3 preparing rook captures
and g4 so now yeah the only move that is
good for black is bishop captures an e3
but it's not a difficult one to find so
hardy of course captures this bishop
captures on e3 rook e captures on e3 and
now knight to g6 and here finally bishop
back to e2 it seems like abdusathrov is
ready to win back his piece but there is
a problem uh there is one move that you
know just uh wins the game on the spot
for hare krishna so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this move
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
white queen on b3 is completely
undefended and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the only move
that saves the game and wins the game
for hari is bishop to e6 this is what he
played and now there really isn't all
that much for white to do here so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you offer your queen for white
queen and europe material of course it
would be completely winning for you so
uh not rebecca cannot afford to trade
queens here he plays queen to b5 but now
queen to f4 and you can't really start
harassing the black queen here hoping
for some sort of a perpetual for example
rook gf3 queen h4 and the bishop covers
h3 so you can forget about that so here
queen the c5 was played going after
queen captures and c7 but not just rook
to h8 harry says you can have all the
material on the queen side you want i'm
going to double up on the h file and
checkmate your king so here queen
captures on c7 there is nothing better
for abu satyarov rook to h6 and now
bishop to f3 but just rook to c8 uh
chasing back away the queen before
playing the rook to h8 queen captures on
a5 and now rook sita h8 preparing rook
to h1 checkmate and there is no good way
to counter this king to f1 was played
rook to h1 check now comes king to e2
and bishop to c4 again with check you
can see that uh there are very very few
squares that the white king can go to d2
being the
only one if you don't want to play rook
to d3 so king to d2 was played and here
there are many moves that win the game
but hari krishna chooses the one that
wins uh uh well basically instantly he
plays rook to f1 and he was in this
position on move 34 that not rebecca
dusatro resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so a
brilliant brilliant victory for hare
krishna with the black pieces against
the so far untouchable no rebecca abdul
satorov who also defeated fabiana
corwana with the black pieces in this
event uh and uh well it basically had a
perfect run but uh you know it's uh
always dangerous playing the the the
joko pianissimo especially if you if you
try to sideline with bishop to g5 like
like it happened here i it's hard to say
you know why he lost exactly but uh he
played an incredibly sharp tactical line
where he simply got outplayed as hari
krishna is an incredibly strong player
so you know
even though abdusatov is the rapid world
champion uh he has to be careful when
facing such strong opposition like like
pentala hari krishna and here you resign
uh basically because there is no defense
against the rook captures on f2 now
there is nothing you can do to stop rook
captures on f2 and after that happens
it's just game over let's say you try
and hide your king just through
characters and f2 checking b1 now rook
h1 check and that's it once you are done
giving a away material uh it will be
checkmate there is nothing you can do
about that
so after this um i wonderful rook to
have one move uh
resigned and a wonderful victory for
penta lahari krishna in round six of the
video olympiad uh we're going to cover
at least one more game and then we are
going to discuss what is happening with
the standings but what i can tell you so
far if you don't want to uh you know uh
listen about the standings then stop
watching the video now uh but the
winners currently are armenia they are
in clear first place uh and uh in the
second place clear second place is
united states with a bunch of teams like
maybe 10 10 teams sharing third place
including uzbekistan india one india two
uh france
and so on
uh so yeah uh once again really hope you
guys enjoyed this uh i would like to
thank esmond alden jacob tobias derek
king felix daffo and casey vance for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad until it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and always
careful when facing the joko pianissimo
see you soon